سيناقش اليوم التالي للحرب لي يناقش اليوم
التالي للحرب ماذا على ماذا استقر الراي
في النهايه فيما يتعلق بذلك وكيف برر
نتنياهو ووسائل الاعلام هذا
القرار هو واضح بان بنيامين نتنياهو لن
يناقش هذا المنحى هذه الليله تحت رضوخا
لهذه الضغوط التي مارسها الجناح المتطرف
في حكومه
المتمثل بوزير الماليه بيتسل ايس موتتش
ووزير الامن القومي تمار بن كفير وهذا ان
دل يدل على الضعف والوهن الذي يعانيه
بنيامين نتنياهو كرئيس للحكومه وهو يدرك
انه بحاجه الى هذه القاعده الشعبيه التي
تتشكل منها حكومته الحاليه لليوم التالي
ما بعد الحرب لان سموتريتش وتمار بنفير
هما الضامن الوحيدان لبقاء حكومته على سده
الحكم في اسرائيل ذلك ان بنيامين م
نتنياهو يدرك تماما انه في اليوم الذي
سيلي انتهاء هذه الحرب فان بيني جانس الذي
انضم الى حكومه الطوارئ سوف ينسحب منها
ولذلك هو يعرف انه مع انسحاب بيني جانس لن
يبقى له الا هؤلاء المتطرفين في حكومته
هذا الجناح المتطرف المتمثل بس سموتريتش
وبينغ فير لذلك هو الغى هذا النقاش لاجل
المحافظه على قوتهما وعلى وجو وجودهما في
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه استقرار توليفته
ما بعد الحرب بنيامين نتنياهو يامل بان
يبقى لاكبر فتره ممكنه على سده الحكم على
ضوء ما تتوقعه استطلاعات الراي من انهيار
حزبه الحاكم وخسارته لنصف قوته اليوم في
اخر استطلاع للقناه الثاله ع الاسرائيليه
هذا الاستطلاع اشار الى ان حزب الليكود
الحاكم يفقد نصف قوته الانتخابيه فيما لو
جرت الانتخابات اليوم ولا يحصل سوى على 16
مقعدا في الكنيست في حين ان غريمه بيني
جانس المتمثل حاليا بث مقعدا في الكنيست
يضاعف قوته ثلاث مرات على الاقل فيما ان
شعبيه بيني جانس في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
تصل الى 52% من الاسرائيليين الذين يرون
بانه الانسب لرئاسه الحكومه فيما يرى ان
31% من الاسرائيليين بان بنيامين نتنياهو
هو الانسب للحكومه لذلك بنيامين نتنياهو
بالغائه هذه المناقشه اليوم هو يريد
المحافظه على القاعده الاساسيه لحكومته
اليمينيه المتطرفه وهي الضامن الوحيد
لبقائه على سده الحكم بنفير كان طالب اصلا
بالغاء مجلس الحرب على اعتباره بانه ليس
مخولا في اتخاذ قرارات سياسيه و بنفير هدد
حتى بالانسحاب من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فيما اذا اتخذ مجلس الحرب قرارا بوقف هذه
الحرب دون تحقيق اهدافها بالقضاء على حركه
حماس عسكريا وسطو في شكرا لك الياس كرام
مراس جزيره كنت معنا من تل ابيب